after the shooting was over I saw all
the victims where they lay the Visions
haunt me in my sleep every night in most
days I cannot get those memories out of
my head
nighttime is the worst for my PTSD I
have night terrors that jerk me awake in
the middle of the night and I'm unable
to come back down to go back to sleep
loud noises never modeled me before but
they do now
I'm always on edge and Hyper Vigilant
about my surroundings feeling the need
to be always on alert and protect myself
I spent 10 days in the hospital endured
four surgeries with two more surgeries
to go my left leg below my knee was
nearly lost and had not been for the
excellent work of my surgeons and the
entire team at ECMC
it takes me at least 15 minutes every
morning just to get out of bed because
my left leg and foot don't work as they
should without the brace on my foot it
drags and I'm not able to flex it I have
no feeling from my knee down to my toe
both of these things are permanent
I just started being able to put my own
sock on and shoe although some shoes I
still have trouble with I'm frustrated
with the things that I haven't been able
to do since my injury
I could speak for hours about my
injuries and treatment as well as the
permanency of these injuries the stress
of not being able to return the work
the pain I suffered hospitalized that
continues to this day
extensive rehab I have gone through
however I would rather talk about being
a Survivor I'm still the same person
than I was before you did this to me my
scars and pain remind me of how strong
I've become I am more alive and stronger
than ever you haven't taken away my will
to live you haven't broken my spirit the
scars are a constant reminder of what
happened to me but don't Define my
future thank you
good morning good morning my name is
Brian Talley I'm here on behalf of
Geraldine Talley and my nephew Mark
Talley
um
paint and Gendron
Peyton Ginger
the reason I'm mentioning your name is
because so many people have spoke about
it
not to say anything not to mention your
name but you need to be known you need
to be known worldwide
I've done a little history on YouTube
Peyton
um
I watched a video
you know and
I'm I just can't believe what can you
say what can you possibly say
after putting on a video
of killing people it was like a video
game to you
what can you possibly say to anybody
your words don't mean anything after
this I'm leaving because I don't want to
hear what you have to say it doesn't
make a difference I'm gonna give you a
little history lesson
the Willie Lynch Doctrine the making of
a Slave
it said you take the biggest the
toughest and the black is near
you take them you tie a horse to one arm
you tie a horse to the other arm you tie
a horse to one leg and tie a horse to
the other leg and then you rip them
apart in front of every slave to let you
know
what it is you did that to us you came
into the biggest part the strongest part
of the black community and you ripped us
apart
how can you possibly
get any kind of
how can you pop
here and say that you're sorry
that you're sorry you're playing this
whole thing
you planned it you put it on a video
like it was a video game and watched it
I watched my sister-in-law get shot by
you I watched it I went in the tops a
couple times and every time I go in
there only thing plays out my mind is
where you walk where you shop what you
did
no
the hatred that you must have in your
heart for black people I would never
understand I don't want to understand it
but I must say this
I pray to God they do not kill you
because I've been incarcerated
I have and I know where you're going
where are you going solitary confinement
for the rest of your life by yourself
wearing this color green that's why I
wore green today because I want you to
remember this color you're gonna be
wearing this color for the rest of your
life I'm praying that you
witness for the rest of your life
I will say this my nephew didn't come
today because of the hate and the pain
that he feel and I don't blame him I do
not blame him because he's still hurting
this whole Community is hurting man you
know you broke it you you divided this
community so much that it's it's painful
we'll never heal for this can you
imagine you wake up on a Sunday morning
and you're going shopping and you're
going shopping on a graveyard because
that's what tops is now it's a graveyard
uh it's a graveyard can you imagine
going to buy your grocery at Forest line
right in the middle of forest line right
now
but that's what you did and if you look
at the community right now on Jefferson
Avenue
after all the hype and everything
nothing has changed as a matter of fact
it's got even worse
it's got even worse doors is closed down
the community is totally devastated and
you did this I would I pray to God
for your soul I forgive you but I
forgive you
not for your sake but for mine and for
this black community I forgive you
because that's the only way we're going
to heal but you can best believe I will
never forget your name I will follow you
every your parole whenever you record
whatever you're going through I'm gonna
follow you just like you followed us
just like you sat down and you followed
us I will always remember your face I
will never ever forget you
thank you
thank you Mr Taylor
good morning good morning
my name is Michelle my last name is
spite
I lost an art on May 14th and a cousin
what are the chances that two of your
family members will be in the same place
from two different sides of your family
this is the first time I really had to
process this for myself as I've been an
advocate for my families that couldn't
be as strong to speak for themselves
the calculated Manifesto that you
derived the way that you started on the
street that I grew up on
you journeyed down my grandmother's
Street and then walked up at tops and
killed two of my family members
my cousin Pamela young that was Pearl
Young was her mother she was her only
daughter
so I stand here to represent
James Young her son Damon young her son
Pamela young her daughter and all of her
grandchildren Ariana Greg Nate and a
host of others
I'm going to read Pamela's statement she
could not be here today
it's entitled residency
what will take up residency will it be
May 14 2022
or the court appearance or every
interview or every time I've had to send
my mother's death certificate to an
insurance company with the cause of
death being multiple gunshot wounds to
the head you didn't shoot her once but
you turned around shower two times
so much so that her
her viewing could not even be made by
her family
I don't
being strange great strength some
mornings I wake up with questions of why
my mother I still recall the day I
viewed my mother's body for the final
time at the funeral home her face held
no familiar semblance and I couldn't
even get her wedding ring on her finger
because so much of her was distorted I
am jealous of my friends and family
because they can remember all the beauty
of her smile and I grapple with my final
image
but then I think
what has the right to take a residency
in my mind
I remember being an eight-year-old girl
traveling with her to UB as she
completed her college degree
the experience of watching her earn her
degree and realizing that I could attain
one
she was my inspiration
I remember my mother's advice on the day
of my marriage her Presence at the
births of all three of my children
there also there was also a Time nearly
15 years ago when she lived with me for
six months she needed to recover from a
major surgery in a home where she could
maneuver around easily my mother spent
those months with me and my husband we
drank coffee together and talked for
hours I was so grateful to be able to
care for her as she had done for me
throughout my childhood
I vividly recall October 31st 2019. the
night my husband passed away
unexpectedly
I arrived at her house full of tears she
brushed my hair as I lay on her lap as
if I were five-year-old girl again
I have so many other memories that I've
decided to write them in my journal
May 14th
will always be a memory of a heinous and
monstrous act of violence perpetuated by
an angry man against my mother simply
because of her race
an act of hatred and white supremacy
but I won't allow it to take up
residency in my mind
not when there is so much more about my
mother that deserves residency there
so when my mind is invaded by May 14
2022 I will allow the tears to fall and
the question of why to utter from my
lips
but afterwards I'll take out my journal
to remember all the precious moments
with my mother
two minutes and three seconds
won't steal those memories
but Peyton
I hope you are haunted every day and
every night
I hope nightmares invade your sleep and
convict and conviction be your constant
companion
you came to Buffalo with hatred and
anger in your heart you terrorized a
community took the life of my best
friend but your anger and hatred is not
greater than my love for my mother
beautiful thoughts of her are in my mind
as I write tonight I I'm reminded of one
of my favorite scriptures and it says
now dear brothers and sisters one final
thing fix your thoughts on what is true
and honorable and right and pure and
lovely and admirable think about things
that are excellent and worthy of Praise
Philippians 4 and 8. this will take up
residency in my mind Pamela young
Pritchett
in the final reading on behalf of the
Morrison family
um specifically
um Fred Morrison and his mother who is
72 who on her birthday buried her son
thanks Peyton for that
dear sirs the Dreadful afternoon of May
14th was the day my world was turned
upside down my life has been altered in
unimaginable ways
the sheer Agony I felt waiting at the
Makowski school for the confirmation
that my brother was one of the victims
of this senseless Massacre by a white
supremacist is riveting
I never imagined my best friend my only
left brother one who I shared holidays
birthdays football game days and most
remarkably our most precious gift we
share in our mom
now all mom and I have left our million
questions of why tons of lifeless
pictures and a plethora of Distant
Memories and countless tears of
insurmountable pain thank you for that
patent
oftentimes my daily struggle is the
feeling of not even wanting to live my
life without him Marcus and I were
inseparable Marcus was the middle son
the only living brother I had the one
that fiercely protected me and my mother
he was preceded in death by my eldest
brother who died suddenly from a heart
attack now guess what Peyton
I'm reliving the pain of loss all over
again on an entire new level
since his murder I sometimes find myself
challenged by not being able to sleep
soundly paranoia going through stores
and in my daily routine always watching
my back as if there was a Target
attached to me
the added responsibility of being the
primary caretaker for our mother who
suffered a stroke
in case you were concerned
and losing capacity to speak
I'm now left as the only child and
pillow she sheds her tears of missing
her baby boy Marcus Morrison on no
mother no mother should have to bury
their child but my mother buried her son
Marcus on her 72nd birthday and marga's
daughter buried her dad on her 16th
birthday
I hope you spend the rest of your life
every second every minute every hour
rehearsing the daunting sound of the
screams and The Echoes of the lives you
snuffed out
I pray that when you blink your eyes
Peyton you close them at night to sleep
and you see images of the slain and
feels a burden of the sorrow from every
family member and friend of the Fallen
loved ones in our entire community of 5
14.
I pray that every second and every
minute of your 24 hours will haunt you
as the absence of my brother at every
birthday holiday Game Day family
gathering and all the other times we
share
they have now become nothing but gloom
and grueling for me and my family
the fact that you can sit in this
courtroom with no remorse
flat affect emotionless
shows the essence of your privilege sir
one that my brother never had and never
will
the fact that you are surrounded by
white officers after you casually
surrendered
while my brother's blood drained from
his body is a testament to society that
we have a long way to go and some
people's blood is just not as important
as others
that's the reason you lived
and you have the privilege of being
protected
needless to say there is one
and I must address you there is one
patent that sees all
and you will not escape the fury of the
Almighty
one scripture is true in the Bible and
that is vengeance is mine saith the Lord
and He will repay
I pray he is merciful because I too need
mercy so I pray he is merciful to let
you live so that you can be reminded of
the innocent blood that my brother
shared behind your calculated Sinister
demonic act that cause my beloved
brother to be snatched from our family
if you don't know God Peyton I invite
you to find him because you are going to
need him with deep sorrow Fred Morrison
brother of Marcus Morrison thank you
your honor thank you
good morning good morning
so I want to start off with saying my
dad was Andre McNeil
hey um went to that store to get a cake
for my little brother because May 14th
is his birthday my little brother's
birthday and he turned three years old
and he didn't get to celebrate his
birthday with his dad because he never
came back
so
um
I was told to write an impact statement
first I was being selfish and I said I
wasn't going to do it but then I
remember I wasn't doing it for this
selfish coward or the courts or the
Press but I was doing it for my dad my
best friend who was snatched from this
world because of something he couldn't
change the color of his skin
after I lost my uncle baby my dad's
brother I made my dad promise me to stay
on top of his house because I didn't
want to lose him and even though we had
separation in life once we did rekindle
we were inseparable I called him for
literally everything especially when I
wasn't getting my way because I knew he
would make a way
but most of all
I would be lost without him because I
finally found somebody who understood me
to a t we thought a lot alike
and even though he had to be dead before
a friend I always respect everything he
said
he was so wise and he made the world
easier to live in because he had all the
answers to my loud questions
when I was around him I wanted
I wanted to know his every move where he
was going what he was doing and I made
sure I tagged along and the one time he
leaves without me
he doesn't come back
after this happened I constantly beat
myself up about
him going
and I'm still pissed off because he
wasn't given a chance to fight he was
blindsided you hit him and he didn't
even know he got hit
he was blindsided by a hateful death at
the hands of a selfish boy who was
obviously not educated on the history of
African Americans and because of you
murdering my dad I'm pissed and I'm sad
and I hate you
and I didn't think I would be strong
enough to look you in the face and tell
you this and how much you hurt me my
little brother who's three years old got
to grow up without his dad
his brothers my dad's sisters his nieces
nephews his grandkids
our dad the man who created us was
killed by a little boy who was obviously
raised by hateful people and I hate your
parents too so let them know that and
there is nothing in this world no amount
of money anything anyone can say that'll
change how I feel
this is the worst way to lose someone
so close to you and I'll never forgive
you and I don't have it in me because no
matter what
it wasn't my time it wasn't my dad's
time to go and who are you to think you
control that
my father Andre mcnell senior his name
will live on until today
I died
so you
I don't know what else to say to you I
just hope you feel bad I really do and I
hope
I just hope you go through it in person
that's all I got to say
thank you
good morning hello I'm Zion Elliott
Andre mcneill's brother
Andre me and Andre are 11 months and
eight days apart
on the 28th I'll turn 53 on March 8th
here 24.
Payton you took this from me you took
the last of my line
my mother died
three days before 9 11. my brother baby
brother died in 2017. my father died in
s I'm all that's left besides my baby
sister
but what I grew up with you took from me
which was my brothers my my last the
oldest the only one I had
the only one I could go to
you know I became a homeless
and he came in and found me and got me
brought me to his house
and surely thus after that you know
he planned a party with my nephew
and asked me to be here you know because
of my work and trying to better my life
I didn't make it
but any other thing in any other day
that he's in Auburn is where he lived
we were born and raised in Buffalo yes
we are from Buffalo
yes this is our home
so you took a lot from me when you came
into Buffalo and you drove past Auburn
you know because conglin's not that far
from Auburn actually
I don't understand why
you know you came all the way to Buffalo
when there was a million different black
communities
but you should have came anywhere you
should have sat in your car first and
thought about your actions
as an 18 year old I don't know how you
could even continue on
I don't know who helped you to talked
you into it
you know because I know a lot of 18 year
olds
white boys so you know this
I know a lot of 18 year old Caucasian
little friends of mine I call them
little homies none of my racist so I'm
confused
especially the three that I know from
Conklin where you're from so I'm
confused on how you got past
everybody
with your ideology
and all this nonsense you have all these
Protectors of you
but so that you know that they're here
now where you're going I've been in your
own kind is going to get you
so you know I've been in that prison
your own kind is going to get you
everything that you think that you know
about prison and whatever they told you
is a lie
trust me I've been there
you can ask anybody here to look up my
name and they'll find three different
New York state ID numbers
which you're about to be
and your own kind is going to get you
they're going to befriend you they're
going to do you real filthy
that's the sad part about it
but you took
53 years from me you took the last of my
life from me
all that I grew up with all that I know
is God
all of it
was all I had
left
and you came in here from New Buffalo on
May 14th and took that from me
I'll never understand why
I don't think anybody will
but you will get what you got coming
you will that is a promise as someone
said Vengeance God says vengeance is
mine
he'll get you
he will get you for all of us
do I hate you no do I want to hurt you
yes and trust me and believe
these dudes can't stop me really
I'm the littlest thing in here and very
agile but I don't want to hurt you
and I don't I got nine children ten
children I gotta go home to Andre had
five
and they can't even they can't beat him
anymore and my nephew
a three-year-old nephew
every day
he's calling for his father
and he can't is that coming
you know how bad that hurts
you know what it's sad when I gotta
ignore my nephew's phone calls to tell
him that daddy's not coming
and said
because that's all he wants to know
and I don't have an answer
but you took a lot from me
you took a lot from my family
but me
the last
I have no mother
no father
no brothers anymore
know what you took
I don't understand
thank you
foreign
ER you've had an opportunity to hear
from some of the victims family members
spoken about the effect that this
heinous racially motivated act had on
them their family members their friends
and their community
however there are additional family
members you've not heard from today
some wrote statements and chose not to
speak
others cannot bear to write a statement
and relive one of the most traumatic
events of their lives
I would like to speak on behalf of all
of those personally affected who chose
not to submit a statement
and then I'd like to speak on behalf of
the DA's office
Hayward Patterson's family members did
not wish to speak today and did not
submit a victim impact letter
nonetheless
I can assure this court that their
reluctance to speak or write a letter is
because of how difficult this process is
which everybody has seen today
everyone who is in toss on May 14th of
2022 or knew someone who was killed on
that day has experienced trauma that is
not easy to speak about
their absence is not an indication that
they don't care about the outcome
or that they've simply moved on
in actuality
it's an indication that they're still
recovering and learning to cope and
cannot yet bring themselves to confront
the defendant or even articulate all of
their feelings in a letter
I'd like to focus on the people who are
at top Supermarket on the day of the
attack for a moment
while there are many people who Escape
that horrible event alive and physically
unharmed they'll be scarred emotionally
for the rest of their lives
I visited the top Supermarket where this
all occurred in the aftermath of the
incident
and it certainly had an immediate effect
on me
and I was only present for a limited
amount of time
I can't imagine what the survivors of
this incident were going through during
the incident
as they remained hidden and quiet
hoping and praying that the defendant
didn't find them and in their lives too
this time yarn I'll speak on behalf of
the DA's office
on May 14th of 2022 this defendant
displayed a callous disregard for human
life
he drove over 200 miles out of his way
with one mission
with one goal
to kill as many black people as possible
during that three-hour drive he could
have turned around
but he wouldn't be deterred he was
steadfast to accomplish his goal of
killing as many black people as possible
and starting a race war
he fed into propaganda and lies they
convinced him that somehow these
innocent people
who you never heard of
who had never heard of him
who had never had a conversation with
him who had never even met him or a
threat to his very existence and
identity as a white man
the defendant executed 10 people and
wounded three others in slightly over
two minutes
the only time he expressed a scintilla
of remorse or regret is when he
apologized to Christopher Braden a white
man for shooting him
any statement of expression or remorse
at this point any tears fall flat
in the face of such violent actions
and I wholeheartedly believe
that the only other regret that the
defendant has
that he didn't kill more black people
before he was apprehended by Buffalo
police officers
in fact the defender was so sure of his
beliefs which were based on lies and
propaganda that he live streamed his
attack with the goal of inspiring others
to commit similar attacks
with the goal of tearing this community
down
the goal
of spreading hatred and fear
he failed
this community is pulled together
people of all Races sexual orientations
and religions working together to show
love and unity for one another
on May 14th of 2022
10 beautiful and innocent lives were
violently taken from their family
friends and community
because the defendant subscribed to
hateful ideology
however their Legacy won't be as victims
struck down by someone with unfathomable
hatred in his heart
but instead it'll be as a beacon of
light that has brought love to this
community
that made this community stronger
that United people of all Races
throughout our community and our country
the defendant's legacy on the other hand
will be of a cowardly murderer who
killed unarmed citizens
the defendant thought that this would
create enough tension to start a race
war that we would return on each other
he thought that everyone has as much
hate in their hearts as he does
but he was wrong
and again he failed
this community showed that they are not
as ugly as the defendant's hateful
ideology and instead of choosing
violence
he chose love
they showed the world that the love of
this community will always be stronger
than white supremacist hatred
and hopefully the defendant will have to
live with his failure for the rest of
his life in a jail cell
while this community continues to
flourish
the honor this sentencing is an
opportunity to say no to racism
to say no to hate
our chance to hold this defendant
accountable and show others that think
like the defendant that these acts have
no place in our society
and that there will be dire consequences
for anyone who tries to follow in his
footsteps
I asked your honor to do what Justice
demands
the sentence is defendant
to the maximum possible sentence
allowable by our laws in New York state
to sentence him to a period of life
without parole
thank you
I had an opportunity to review the
pre-sentence investigation and is there
anything you'd like to make a record
about with regard to that
have had an opportunity to do it we have
nothing to add anything thank you
anything further from the people
no you're on thank you
I want to acknowledge
that today is what
I Can Only Imagine
one of many solemn days in the lives of
the survivors
and the family members of those who died
their words are heart-wrenching
they're lost unimaginable
only those who have lived it
can truly understand their anguish
for the devastation that he caused
Peyton Gendron will be sentenced to
spend the rest of his life in prison
with no possibility of ever being
released
our client committed these terrible
crimes
he is responsible for his actions
and he will be held accountable
and he will suffer the consequences
for what he did
this case highlights however
a much deeper problem
this young man's violent hate-filled
assault
was in part
the product of centuries of pervasive
racism
and discrimination in this country
these problems need to be addressed
just as many others have publicly
demanded since this terrible event took
place
unfortunately
neither this proceeding
nor any criminal trial
can expose or address the historical
racism
that set the stage for our clients
horrible Acts
we
as a community
need to have those conversations
in our legislative bodies
and in our living rooms
to achieve meaningful change
we know that some of the families and
their lawyers
have asked for the information collected
by law enforcement
during their investigations of this
crime
we support that request
we hope the resolution of this case
brings the day for that information to
be shared closer
the racist hate that motivated this
crime
was spread through online platforms
in the violence that was made possible
was in part due to the easy access of
assault weapons
still our client is responsible for this
crime
he will spend the rest of his life
locked away
and eventually he will die in State
Prison
we hope that knowing he will never be
free again
will offer some small bit of comfort
to those that he hurt so much
some of those most affected by his crime
have expressed a need to know
whether our client is remorseful
remorseful for what he did
and the devastation that he caused
we are aware however
that for others
any expression of remorse
would be meaningless
in the very sight of him
or the sound of his voice can be painful
at this time
he has a brief statement to make
his words are not in any way
intended to reflect any further pain
on those that have already suffered
and we hope that they do not do so
thank you thank you
foreign
I forced the victims and they were
families to suffer through
I'm very sorry for stealing the lies of
your loved ones
I cannot express how much I regret all
the decisions I made leading up to my
actions on May 14th
I didn't terrible thing that day
I shot and killed people because they
were black
but getting back now I can't believe I
actually did it
I believed what I read online and acted
out of hate
I know I can't take it back but I wish I
could
and I don't want anyone to be inspired
by me and what I did
you don't be done
has the defense had an opportunity to
review the pre-sentence investigation
and is there any record you wish to make
with regard to that
judge we have had a chance to review the
presents report and we have no comment
on it at this point
is there any further comment the defense
wishes to make no we are ready for
sentencing okay
I would like to thank you all for being
here
and to thank those of you
who have shared your thoughts and
feelings with the courts either in
writing or an open court here today
it is very meaningful to me
and I believe that it is important for
the defendant
and the world to hear what you have to
say
I am very sorry
for your losses and the pain that you
feel
I would like to recognize
the heroic officers of the Buffalo
Police Department
who without hesitation
ran towards the danger of an active
shooter call
swiftly and professionally stopping and
containing the defendant
and putting an end to his evil Rampage
thank you
I spent a lot of time thinking about
this case
our community
our nation
how we got here
and where we go from here
it all comes down to character
and having the strength to stand up for
what is right
our character
is not defined by the good and easy
times
it is defined by the hard and
challenging times
and often
our character is revealed not
necessarily by what we say
but by what we do
I am both immensely proud of and
grateful for the way Buffalo has
rejected the evil and hate that was
inflicted on our community
the character of good people
throughout this city
County
State Nation
and even internationally
has shown through as they have stood
with the victims of this heinous and
cruel Act
this indictment
speaks to the 13 victims and their
families
that lost the most
but they are not the only victims
there are thousands
that have been traumatized directly and
vicariously
by this defendant's actions
we have seen the community turn out in
support
and are seeing signs of much needed
change in East Buffalo
it is a testament to the power of love
and compassion
to overcome evil and Hate
by turning pain into purpose
but it is just the beginning
we have a long way to go
this hateful Act and other similar
hateful acts across the country
motivated by white supremacy
and replacement Theory
are a reckoning for us as a nation
The Ugly Truth
is that our nation was founded and built
in part on white supremacy
starting with the treatment of Native
Americans by the first European settlers
to the cruel inhumane economic engine
nation-building practice of slavery
to indentured servitude
to Jim Crow laws
to government policies creating
segregated public housing
with communities of color often placed
in environmentally hazardous locations
to the manner in which expressways were
built
dividing Urban neighborhoods to create
easy access to government subsidized
developments in the suburbs
with restricted governance
prohibiting the sale of suburban homes
to African Americans
two redlining practices in communities
of color
further devaluing those neighborhoods
to the GI Bill
a well-deserved Financial boom to our
servicemen
unless of course you were a serviceman
of color
to the War on Drugs
and mass incarceration
disproportionately of men of color
to the school to prison pipeline
to win equities in education
employment opportunities and
compensation
to the existence of food deserts
and inaccuracies in health care
our history is replete with both
individual and systemic discriminatory
practices
many of them still firmly in place today
in fact
it is these very policies and practices
that contributed to and made this
atrocity possible
the effects of these policies
some current and others decades and
centuries old
created the segregation in our city
and enabled this defendant
to research and identify his Target to
maximize the impact of his evil intent
all of these policies and systems
either sponsored or tolerated by the
government
and implemented by individuals
were designed to destroy the very fabric
of family life
opportunities for success
the creation of generational wealth
and even the mere existence of Hope in
communities of color
the harsh reality
is that white supremacy
has been an Insidious cancer on our
society and Nation since its Inception
and it undermines the Notions of
ameritocracy in the land of opportunity
that we hold so dear
however white supremacy
is not inevitable
or Unstoppable
it has been carefully cultivated and
nurtured by individuals and the
government for centuries
this is the history that we have all
inherited
it has been passed down from generation
to generation
we must acknowledge that history
see that history for what it is
recognize it
and learn from it
or we are doomed to repeat it
let ours be the generation to put a stop
to it
we can do better
we must do better
our own Humanity requires it
as an individual
we must call out Injustice in our daily
lives when we see it
we must reject racism
in all of its forms
we must be conscious of the power of our
words and actions
and the impact they have on those around
us
both intended and unintended
we must demand better of our public
servants
in their efforts to address inequity
and we must Embrace government policies
aimed at creating and fostering
diversity equity and inclusion
we must make the outpouring of support
love and compassion
that followed this heinous act
and everyday practice
we are stronger together
these are hard and challenging times
our characters are being tested
the future of our nation is at stake
are we up to the challenge
I believe that we are
in the words of poet laureate Amanda
Gorman
there is always light
if only we are brave enough to see it
if only we are brave enough
to be it
Mr Gendron please stand
there is no place for you or you're
ignorant
hateful and evil ideologies in a
civilized society
there can be no mercy for you
no understanding
no Second Chances
the damage you have caused is too great
and the people you have hurt are too
valuable to this community
you will never see the light of day as a
free man ever again
it is the Judgment of this court
for your conviction under the first
count of the indictment
a domestic Act of terrorism motivated by
hate in the first degree
an A1 felony
that you be sentenced to life
imprisonment without parole
under the second count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of Roberta Drury
a vibrant 32 year old young woman
a daughter
a dedicated sister and friend
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the third count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of 67 year old Hayward
Patterson
a son father and friend
known as a faithful hard-working
generous well-dressed man
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the fourth count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of 77 year old Pearl
Young
a daughter
mother
grandmother and friend
known for being a loving dedicated
substitute teacher
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the fifth count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of 86 year old Ruth
Whitfield
a daughter
sister
wife
mother and grandmother
a dedicated caretaker
an avid fisherwoman
and a valued member of her Church
community
I'm imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the Sixth count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of Celestine Cheney
a daughter
sister mother
and
grandmother and friend
a fighter who had 65 had beat cancer and
multiple aneurysms
a person who enjoyed life and laughed
easily
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the seventh count of the
indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of Aaron Salter
age 55.
a son
brother
husband and father
a car guy
and a lover of camping
a retired Buffalo police officer
heroic and selfless to the very end
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the eighth count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of 53-year-old Andre
McNeil
a son
brother uncle
father and fiancee
devoted Miami Heat fan
survived by a three-year-old son
I am imposing a sentence
of life imprisonment without parole
under the ninth count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of Marcus Morrison
age 52.
a son
brother
husband and father
he loved music and sneakers
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the tenth count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of 72 year old Catherine
Massey
cat
a daughter
sister
aunt and friend
an activist known for her sincerity
thoughtfulness and honesty
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
under the 11th count of the indictment
murder in the first degree
for the murder of Geraldine Talley
age 62.
a daughter
mother and Aunt
the life of the party and a top-notch
baker
I am imposing a sentence of life
imprisonment without parole
by operation of law the sentences on
counts 2 through 11.
must run concurrently with the sentence
imposed on the first count
under the remaining counts of the
indictment to which you pled
the law permits me based on your age to
consider granting you youthful offender
status
the purpose of youthful offender status
under the law is to prevent the stigma
stigmatization of young offenders
based on Hasty and thoughtless Acts and
to provide them a fresh start
and A Renewed opportunity to be a
law-abiding productive member of society
however given the manner in which you
methodically planned
researched conducted recognizance
and executed your hateful crimes
a finding of youthful offender status is
not appropriate
there has was nothing Hasty or
thoughtless about your conduct
there are no mitigating factors to be
considered
you will be sentenced as an adult on the
remaining counts
under the 22nd count of the indictment
attempted murder in the first degree
for the attempted murder of
twenty-year-old Zaire Goodman
a beloved Son
a hard-working young man of character
I am imposing the maximum determinant
sentence of 25 years followed by five
years of post-release supervision
I direct this sentence to run
consecutively to all other sentences
imposed
under the 23rd count of the indictment
attempted murder in the first degree
for the attempted murder of 55 year old
Christopher Braden
a son father
husband and friend
a professional
serving the needs of the good people of
the City of Buffalo
I'm imposing the maximum determinant
sentence of 25 years followed by five
years of post-release supervision
I direct this sentence to run
consecutively to all other sentences
imposed
under the 24th count of the indictment
attempted murder in the first degree
for the attempted murder of Jennifer
warington
age 50.
daughter
mother
wife
friend
a professional serving the needs of the
good people of the City of Buffalo
I am imposing the maximum determinant
sentence of 25 years followed by five
years of post-relief supervision
I direct this sentence to run
consecutively to all other sentences
imposed
under the 25th count of the indictment
criminal possession of a weapon in the
second degree
I am imposing the maximum determinant
sentence of 15 years followed by five
years of post-release supervision
I direct this sentence to run
consecutively to all other sentences
imposed
I am assessing the mandatory surcharge
of three hundred dollars the crime
Victim Assistance fee of twenty five
dollars and a DNA fee of fifty dollars
you have 30 days to appeal the sentence
of this court
this concludes these proceedings and the
court will stand in recess
foreign